[Music]
and welcome to this Friday night's
special edition of Hannity now tonight
the Biden Administration they're barely
Treading Water polls are bad the economy
is bad the Border well that's a
nightmare the cost of energy now once
again through the roof crime out of
control all over the country rampant
homelessness the likes of which we
haven't seen in a long time and the
president can barely string together a
coherent sentence without assistance and
Biden's weaponized Department of Justice
well they've lost all credibility and
well what's happening now we have new
allegations of possible misconduct
against the doj the Attorney General
Garland and his minion David Weiss
they're just flat out lying how do we
know because now yet another IRS
whistleblower testified that the doj's
tax attorneys and Hunter Biden's legal
team had an unusually close working
relationship how convenient we have full
details of that all coming up we'll
check in with Judge Jeanine Pirro first
a message from your president of the
United States Joey Biden while speaking
at the annual Galler for the
Congressional Hispanic caucus well Biden
apparently thought he was speaking in
front of the Congressional Black Caucus
I know an innocent mistake right take a
look
therefore my dad taught me and I mean
this sincerely my dad would say everyone
everyone is entitled to be treated with
dignity and respect
Congressional Black Caucus embodies all
those values that's a different caucus
anyway just a little confused in fact
he's been a little confused pretty much
all week his short-term memory loss is
becoming a real uh problem that's a
problem for the country and for the
world is that a fundraiser he tells the
exact same story not once but twice in
just a matter of minutes word for word
also walked away from an event with
Brazil's president forgetting to shake
his hand say goodbye Biden seemingly
forgot that Brazil's president was even
standing there it's kind of hard to
believe that this guy wants another four
years you know working at what should be
the most demanding and hardest job on
Earth take a look for one day
for one day my Administration the United
States
has treated this crisis
as an existential threat from the moment
we took office
not only for us
but for all of humanity now he has the
Evolve our institutions and drive
creative new Partnerships let me be
clear
certain principles are International
System are sacrosanct accompanied by the
director general of the international
labor organization President Biden can
you hear me
you can yes
and so
there's the U.S delegation that is here
with me not to deceive you Mr President
[Applause]
no Nation can be truly secure in the
world if in fact we don't stand up
and the freedom of freedom of Ukraine
from the face of this Russian brutality
and aggression they finally beat big
farm I've been fighting it since I've
been a fun freshman
sad it's humiliating it's embarrassing
for the country his cognitive struggles
might actually be the least of his
problems we got a new poll showing that
nearly half of you the American people
support the impeachment inquiry against
Joe Biden they believe that Biden is
corrupt and he should be held
accountable meanwhile Biden and Trump
well they're beyond a dead heat Trump
now winning in most polls CBS poll uh
even has Trump at the all-import look at
this 50 percent threshold that's a big
number voters are now giving Biden low
marks for the economy inflation and his
age is obviously a massive concern among
the American people who are also rightly
appalled at Biden's border crisis you
know which has been critical from day
one even though they say oh the board is
closed oh no the board is secured no
it's not according to Griff Jenkins last
year's records two plus million illegal
immigrant encounters has already been
topped so far this year so year number
one he set a record year number two he
set a record and once again the third
year of his presidency yep he set a
record more than 2.3 million so far this
year have been apprehended by border
patrol and pretty much led into the
country that's an average of 9 000
illegal immigrants every single day and
don't forget about you know Biden's new
program to help illegal immigrants just
fly directly don't bother going to the
Border it makes me look bad so well he
gives them the option of flying directly
into the interior of the United States
you have a choice of 43 locations
wherever you want to land and Biden what
we're calling the Biden app allows
people all over the world to just sign
up and get their flight so far over 220
000 illegal immigrants have used the
program they don't have to even go to
the Border Joe has a charter jet waiting
for them no background checks that we
know of no help checks that we know of
are they going to be able to house
themselves are they going to be able to
afford health care they're going to be
able to afford food and and water
clothing are they going to be able to
afford anything what about our school
system is it they ready for that anyway
they skipped the long Border Lines
because it makes Joe looks bad and now
it makes illegal immigration so much
easier it's more streamlined just we'll
fly you in just tell us you want to come
of course the vetting that's not good
there are just too many illegals pouring
across this country's borders to conduct
a thorough background on anybody that
background check is necessary as a
result criminals have now come across
including violent individuals who
murdered and raped American citizens now
of course Terror cells yeah guess what
thanks to Joe Biden uh I would bet
everything I have he has allowed people
either on the terror watch list or fully
associated with terrorists into this
country and they are plotting planning
scheming against we the American people
and meanwhile those trying to immigrate
well legally and pay taxes they're push
to the back of the line you know with
some of the longest wait times in the
history of this country it makes no
sense it is not the rule of law as a
matter of fact he's aiding and abetting
the law breaking but there's no sign of
this crisis ever slowing down in fact
it's picking up speed you know Biden
could reinstate the state of Mexico
policy he could use the economic levers
to force the Mexican Government to
control their own border he could build
more border wall and hire more border
agents but instead well you've seated
all control of our Southern border to
Mexican cartels now remember he employed
a similar tactic in Afghanistan when he
allowed the Taliban to conduct all
security outside the airport right
outside their walls that makes sense no
because as we abandon Americans Behind
Enemy Lines we abandoned our allies
Behind Enemy Lines and where's the
borders are Kamala Harris's VP you
pointed her to that position over two
years ago and you know apparently takes
uh with you know Finding solutions to
this crisis you know talks about it
regularly but he doesn't come up with
anything during that time the crisis
only got worse so naturally Biden
rewarded her with a new Mission oh she
didn't even make it to the real border
where the problem is uh he was down
there once for just a couple hours he
didn't see where the problem was either
she will now serve as the
administration's gun controls are with a
goal to end gun violence in America as
we know it let me tell you how that's
going to end they're going to want to
take away your right to keep and bear
arms now I wonder if she'll even step
foot uh maybe in the south side of
Chicago or West Baltimore or South
Central L.A or New York City thousands
of people shot shot and killed every
single year you don't know their names
because they can't politicize those
shootings or is she going to use the
same tactic that we saw at the border
and do absolutely nothing hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else